roll on 2022
german companies are
expecting big things from next year
despite all the concerns about new
coronavirus variants and supply chain
shortages that's according to the latest
annual survey by the cologne institute
for economic research they asked 48
business associations representing
almost 3 000 companies about their
prospects for 2022 and you'll see that
39 of them say they expect higher
production or
greater business activity next year the
other nine say things are supposed to
say they expect things to stay around
the same level not a single association
expected their sector to be worse off in
2022 than 2021
now a wide variety of industries are
optimistic almost across the board
really among them are machine and plant
manufacturers we've also got retailers
the it sector and is banking on more
security contracts next year and uh last
but not least we've also got
construction and the pharmaceuticals
sector however when it comes to creating
new jobs the survey is not quite as
bullish only 21 out of the 48
associations say that their sectors will
be hiring more people among the
manufacturers and electronic equipment
and uh craft workers uh 19 of them said
that the number of employees will remain
the same while
eight
of the business associations are
actually planning to cut staff next year
well let's discuss the findings of the
survey further with the director of the
cologne institute for economic research
mikhail huter thank you very much for
joining us on dw business just to
explain to us
why there's so much optimism among
german businesses at the moment
i think three arguments make clear why
the german business sector is optimistic
first we are still out of the way of
crisis and the year 2021 was a
disappointing year because we expect
more growth and we faced all the
supply-side problems you mentioned
already
and this year and the next year 2020
will be a year of catching up again and
we will hope to come to the pre-crisis
level again so it's still a year of
catching up second um we
have a lot of
in in the other statistics of the german
business vector very
nearly on the historical level on the
highest level
so there is no demand side problem the
only problem we have the only maybe
micro budget it's the supply side
problems you mentioned so we
expected the germ business as in in the
general expect that they will solve the
problem next year so all this is base is
the basis for optimism but more most
important we have no demand side
problems
in germany we do have the omicron
variant now and case numbers are rising
how are businesses feeling about that
are they factoring that in when they
think about how how good 2022 is going
to be for them
yeah we asked the enterprise the
companies end of november and the first
half of december so that was still in
the situation that they were faced with
the fact that there is a new uh very
very a
virus called omicron
but what can you do you can only ask for
more flexibility an agile production
scheme you can
try to be flexible in the in the usage
of your workforce and all this already
done and the companies are working on
the vaccination campaign so
this is not a very simple task to to
make a forecast on the omicron the wave
may be strong but without a
smaller impact on on the hospitality
situation nobody knows and the variety
is between stand still of production
that will be the worst case and an
ongoing production and maybe the best
case that we have not really an effect
on that so in this case you can only ask
for flexibility
and you mentioned about supply chain
problems that's obviously having a
knock-on effect we're seeing inflation
as a result of that we're seeing higher
energy bills as well
is that expected to resolve itself
during 2022
yeah it takes more time as we expected
during the year 21 but for next year the
companies are indicating that they will
see an ongoing uh
lower problems on the supply side the
logistics systems which are
really in the trouble due to the closing
of ports in east asia for example have
we we expect to to solve these problems
they will come back on on a new quality
on logistics and the companies react as
already mentioned with higher stocks so
right
this is still uncertain but there are
more hope that will solve the problem
next year and this will
most important for coming up with all
the demand which is still in the order
statistics okay michael hutter director
of the cologne institute for economic
research thank you for joining us this
morning
welcome
you